I hope so. I mean,
I had a great interview with Colin Quinn and he just had a book come out and he
was talking about how we live in such crazy times that the extremes
are telling the independence that they're crazy. And he is, he was saying,
you know, this is the majority of people.
How crazy is it that people eat? He's like, they're the craziest,
they're the ideologues.
It's locals week here on the Rubin report.
And I'm doing a series of mini interviews with creators on why they decided to
become less reliant on big tech and instead own their content,
community and livelihood with locals.com.
Joining me today is comedian and hosted the dumpster fire. Bridget fettuccine.
Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me always a pleasure.
Nice to see you again, before we get into your,
your locals community.
And you were literally the first person that I got on locals besides
me. Um, I thought,
I thought we'd talk a little bit about why I thought you'd be the right person.
And it's because you are trying sorta like I'm trying, I think,
to bring a little civility back to discourse, how's that going for you?
It's going well in the community. I mean,
it is the last VATE. We did a live chat,
which was really fun because that's like the best feature ever that
brings everybody back to kind of a chat room bag, which is amazing.
And everybody loved it. And we did. And you know, I had some Biden supporters.
I'm completely independent.
Some people who just aren't voting people who are pro-Trump,
all of us were in the chat. Everybody was laughing, nobody,
and nobody was fighting. It was very several people were having disagreements,
but still being cordial to one another. It was amazing.
So I believe that it's still out there.
Is it weird that you have to sort of cultivate a space for that? Like,
I think what intrinsically comes to people like me and you pretty obviously
pretty simply naturally that these days it's just like gone.
Yeah. I think it's,
I feel like it's less gun in real life than it is online.
So I think if you've got a group of people together,
they probably would,
even if they fell all across the political spectrum,
I would hope they would manage to be civil.
And I imagine they would be more soulful than perhaps they would be online.
Although everybody being quarantined and being online,
I feel like some of that decorum has eroded in that time and
people are forgetting how to behave online and off completely.
And they're becoming more and more kind of polarized or entrenched in their own
beliefs.
So it seems like things because of the
pandemic, it kind of accelerated this already, um,
rude and nasty tone that we were already seeing amongst people.
But I do think, you know, unline, it's worse.
Obviously people are much there. We are anonymous.
It's U P I G I really encourage people in the community to use their name,
to use their picture too,
so that we can get to know each other and help each other and have it feel more
like a neighborhood and less like a social media where everybody's just,
you know, outwitting each other and trying to be the snarky. Just.
The things that you,
you push a lot that I always appreciate is that it's not all about politics.
Like even if you love politics,
even if you live politics and I love politics and what I've been doing for a
long time, but that, that life is just not about only that.
Yeah, I, I hate politics
and falling into this space has made me hate them even more.
And it's only affirmed everything that I believed before I knew anything about
politics, which is that they're dirty and they bring out, um,
kind of the worst in people. And, and it's,
it's not my favorite topic. And my community is very, you know, I'm,
I'm sober. So I,
I try to talk a lot about just what I've learned in coping tools.
I feel grateful to have learned it in sobriety.
You don't have to be sober to have access to a lot of this stuff.
And my whole, you know,
podcasts walk-ins welcome is about grit and resilience.
And so I do my best to that psychological cultivation of
that attitude is really the most important thing to me.
And I think in the community,
that's the vibe of everybody supporting each other.
I have workouts with the girls five days a week.
So we do zoom workouts and it's been amazing. I mean,
this community has truly saved me throughout quarantine.
And then the pandemic just keeping me on the beam and working out
and working on ourselves and sharing goals.
And I've seen people help each other through death.
I've seen people help each other help each other through health struggles.
It's just been really inspiring to see, you know,
this virtual community support each other, the way that community should. Yeah.
Well, it's funny to me because you're right.
Like we all got sort of jammed online even more because of
COVID we knew there was like a problem with the online discourse and then the,
the solution somehow is that we're all online,
even more and doing everything there. And it's like, we need those spaces.
I'm having dinners with people in the community and,
and we've hired several people for Rubin report and for locals that have come
out of the community and all that. Um,
one of the things that I think you're trying to do also is,
is carve out a space for people to still be, to still be centrist.
Do you, do you think the centrist can survive? The, uh,
the crazy part is in times that we live in.
I hope so. I mean,
I had a great interview with Colin Quinn and he just had a book come out and he
was talking about how we live in such crazy times that the extremes
are telling the independence that they're crazy. And he, he was saying,
you know, this is the majority of people.
How crazy is it that people he's like, they're the crazies,
they're the ideologues,
they're the ones who are extreme and will die on whatever hell and carry,
you know, whatever water they need to carry,
to justify whatever they need to justify to themselves.
And I think people in the middle, you know, more than anything,
I just want people to be okay with expressing confusion or expressing
doubt or expressing uncertainty or expressing the,
I don't know, that's a perfectly acceptable answer.
And these times it is crazy out there. And so.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Are you saying you don't know how much yellow cake uranium,
or as in the year end centrifuges.
Did they even put yellow.
Cake uranium in centrifuges? That just sounds like something.
I know, less than nothing.
The more I've entered into this realm. I, the more I've realized,
I know it's so very little about anything,
and it's easy to just get online and become an expert in whatever
is trending because that's,
you can Wikipedia things and become this kind of armchair expert and any single
thing that pops up. But really,
we don't know that much unless we are experts.
And I I'm okay with being kind of the,
the dummy who is asking a lot of questions.
And that's the other thing I'm noticing is that people are afraid to even ask
questions. It's not even vote for XYZ. If you don't say,
if you say I'm not voting or voting third party,
you will basically be called a fascist as well.
Fascinate it's fat. It's fascinating to me to just see how,
um,
that there's a loss of people being able
to speak their three and honest opinion and truth,
and so more important than anything is that we all
continue to cultivate spaces where that's okay.
Where people feel like they can just say, I mean,
I can't tell you how many emails I get from people who are politically home
homeless, who are like, I don't even care if you read this.
That just felt so good to say because they, they don't have anywhere.
They can express us.
So I'm hoping that my community can be that place where people can, um,
express their confusion. I think Jack Kerouac had a great quote.
I have nothing to offer the world, but my confusion,
I feel like that's very much my vibe.
Yeah. Yeah. Well,
when I've jumped into your community and I just kind of see what's going on,
it's like people are sharing other things besides politics and they're trying
to help each other out.
And it's like that really remember the word social is in social media.
It's like it was supposed to make right.
Foodies and what'd you have for dinner and all that. That's my, I mean,
half and half of my community is just doing recipes and dinners, but it's like,
you're smiling as you're saying it, because it's like, Oh,
there's something good happening there. But it's, it's like,
people are on Twitter just telling you how miserable they are all day long.
And yet we're there too. So irony, whatever. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean,
I like Twitter because I really feel like it's the
Thunderdome. So you get to just, it it's,
it's very hard to be free there too.
And I like to challenge myself on Twitter because
it's an exercise in what I'm not saying. So when it first started,
when I first went on Twitter and started getting notice,
even by people on the right, uh, you'll lean into what's working.
And I generally have this rule where wherever I have a tweet that goes really
big, I'll do the opposite.
Or I'll say something just so that I can weed out anybody who might think that
I'm too much of a, um, w you know, you can see one tweet and be like,
Oh, I know who this person is,
but I need to weed out the people who can't handle differing
opinions, because on both sides, there are people who can I handle it?
You're saying anything bad about Trump or anything bad about the left.
Yeah. Where do you see the internet going in the next couple of years?
You think that you think these, these big things that they'll bell exist still,
it seems like everything's kind of crumbling. Maybe they'll look very different.
I've been asking everybody this question.
Yeah. That's a good question. Um,
I don't know where anything will be in two years or three in,
in the future. I feel like it,
all of the things that we never could have considered possible are
playing out are happening. So I have to really,
really get my mind around being comfortable with being
uncertain and not really having any idea what I think Twitter will
survive. My, my feeling, even seeing them,
my 12 year old nephew now loves Twitter,
because it is the fastest social media in terms of the conversation.
And it is this think tank for all of these kinds of thought
people. Um, and the conversation is kind of happening there.
I wouldn't be surprised as if it survives, but it,
it seems,
it seems like the forces
to silence people.
And I'm seeing this even like I was in clubhouse last night. Holy crap.
I mean, wow.
Wow. I don't even know really. I got an invite a long time ago.
Like I logged on once and I was like, I don't need to like,
listen to these people talking. I dunno, like we need more of it.
It's amazing. You know, what I really love about it.
Is that it's basically like being at a conference and you can just go pop in and
listen to a panel of speakers. That's how I see it.
But then with the introduction of people that make people in there not
feel safe, it's caused a lot of discussion,
the same discussions that happen on every single platform about who's allowed to
be speaking, who is allowed to be where. And so this is the,
this is the conversation that I think will alter all of these
platforms. The most, you know, Twitter, Facebook,
who is allowed to speak where,
and why I love locals is because I feel like on mouse and
I have talked about this. At least we get a phone call before we get booted.
I mean, you can do whatever you want. It's up to you.
As long as you're not breaking the laws of the United States, you know,
you've shown a little, a little more skin than say I've shown on mine. But, uh,
as long as I don't care what you do in there, I mean the whole, the whole,
you know, development team, they don't care. It's your community. It's like,
we're just giving you some tools. You go, you go do what you want.
Yeah, it's great. It feels very free. And I liked that. And I, I, you know,
it's really empowering in that. I have it,
it goes through, um, like my Stripe account.
I feel like that's the most empowering thing because I've been a lot of these
other sites and it's goes to them. We get paid out. We have to wait.
It's, this is truly giving the creators,
the tools to their audience and access to their audience and not being a
gatekeeper because, and in this time, when there are gatekeepers everywhere,
and you can just get booted off a platform and sorry,
you now have to fight for your stuff and fight for your audience.
And now scramble to tell everybody this feels a lot more
empowering. And I think that that is the future. And it's the,
it's the most exciting, one of the most exciting things,
other than just the sexiness of the actual design and
platform about locals for me as a creator.
Yeah. Just to be clear for people that don't get what you're saying,
it's your Stripe account. Meaning if you're a crater on there, right.
It's your personal Stripe account.
So we locals doesn't collect the money on your behalf and then pay you,
your paid as people sign up, then locals gets their cut,
but it all goes through you. So there's no, there's no middleman.
Yeah, exactly. And in my case, they're subscribing to fettucine Inc. I mean,
this is, this is an amazing,
and people just kind of assume that that's the way it was,
was because, um, that's the way it is.
And the fact that locals has made that very small,
but obvious shift in the way that this works is I think,
um, enormously important for creators in this space,
moving forward when things are shifting and, and, um,
people are being de platformed and silenced and, and booted.
Fantasy. You're making me look good for picking you first.
I'm a business woman.
All right. Well, everyone can go to fed izzy.locals.com or just fed izzy.com,
just redirects to locals. And I hope to see you in real life, one of these days.
Yeah.
I know. No, I know it's,
it's overdue. I will set it up,
but thank you for creating this and thank you to the team.
You have an amazing team behind you and working with you,
and they're all very loving and supportive and, and brilliant and talented.
So I appreciate all their help.
And I want them to know that I see how hard they work and what they're doing,
and it's, it's not, it doesn't go unnoticed with me or my community.
I hear about it all the time from them. So thank you.
Well, I love to hear that and they'll be happy to hear that. All right, Bridget,
we'll talk soon.
All right. Thank you.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.